you need to value certain things in
order to get any facts in hand in the
first place any statement about facts
relies on having first valued
things like evidence and logical
coherence right if you're if you don't
value logic
there's no logical argument you can give
someone to say that they should value it
if someone doesn't value evidence
there's no evidence you could give them
to say that they should value it so that
so it you know epistemology sort of
bites its own tail
or put or picks itself up from its boot
right now that actually that actually
harkens back to the is ought problem
right because
right there you said
and i'm not denying the validity of
anything you've said so far but right
there you said that
without agreeing on the validity of
evidence let's say
there's no
agreement about what is
and there we've got a frame problem
there right
we have that value that you need to even
determine what is well the question then
is well where does that value come from
and you can't say well it comes from
what is in some easy manner because you
just said unless you have a value of a
certain sort you can't derive what is
and that's partly why this ought to is
ought problem
just doesn't seem to go away
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone i'm pleased today in a
variety of ways to
have as my guest dr sam harris
who
is undoubtedly familiar to many of you
watching or listening to this sam is a
neuroscientist philosopher and author of
five new york times bestsellers his work
covers a wide range of topics
neuroscience moral philosophy religion
meditation practice political
polarization
rationality
but generally focuses on our developing
understanding of ourselves and
how how our developing understanding of
ourselves and the world is changing our
sense of how we should live
his books include the end of faith the
moral landscape free will lying and
waking up
sam hosts the popular making sense
podcast there's also the creator of the
waking up app which we're going to talk
about a fair bit today which offers a
modern rational approach to the practice
of meditation
and an ongoing exploration of what it
means to live a good life
he's practiced meditation for more than
30 years and has studied with many
tibetan indian burmese and western
meditation teachers both in the us and
abroad
he holds a degree in philosophy from
stanford and a phd in neuroscience
from ucla
sam and i spoke twice a few years ago
it's probably four years ago now on his
podcast we got bogged down a bit the
first time trying to agree on a
definition of truth which in our defense
is not necessarily the easiest thing to
come to an agreement on but our second
discussion flowed more freely then we
met twice in front of live audiences of
about 3 000 in vancouver and soon after
at dublin and then at the o2 in london
those were tremendously exciting events
i believe for both of us and for
everyone else involved and perhaps even
for the audiences where something
approximating nine thousand and eight
thousand people respectively listen to
our
discussions and we haven't spoken
well for a long time perhaps not since
then even
and i so i'm very much looking forward
to this and the time i first thing i'd
really like to know is
what do you make of
those events in retrospect and
they attracted a very large crowd
certainly by our standards and
i'd like to know
how you look back on that and and what
you think about that well first let me
say i'm just very happy to to see you
and to be speaking with you again it's
really it's been
uh i think we spoke once on the phone
since those events if i'm not mistaken
but
you know it's been the years passed
quickly or all too slowly depending on
what's going on as you know and uh you
know i've heard about
a lot of what you've gone through
indirectly and
what you put out there publicly and i
just you know i was you know i was i was
worried about you and i'm incredibly
gratified to see you
re-emerge and and uh connect with
your audience and and uh be back be back
in the game because thanks man i value
your voice
yeah well it's i i'm pretty thrilled to
be back and to be able to be talking to
people again like this so
let's hope it continues yeah yeah
um
well you know it was very interesting
because i mean you know as you know and
as as your
your fans know you you really did kind
of come out of nowhere
like a you know on a rocket like
trajectory right so you were somebody i
had never heard of
and then all of a sudden you were the
most requested
person
for my from my audience to have on the
podcast
and then we did that first podcast that
you mentioned where we we got bogged
down on questions of epistemology and um
which i you know i think i haven't
listened to it since but i i still think
it was a useful conversation and
not god is going yeah and many people
found it very valuable i mean you know
it's just to either to my advantage or
your advantage people found it valuable
uh they heard what they
some heard what they wanted to hear in
it and some
some had their minds uh bent around as
as was intended
but
uh
people most people many people certainly
felt felt it was a kind of failed
experiment in conversation and we should
try it again
and then we had a a much more amicable
discussion
on my podcast and that planted the seed
for these
public events
and
if if memory serves we had one event
booked in vancouver
and you were still not quite the famous
jordan peterson yet
and then in like in the
15 days it took us to actually get to
that event
um
your star had risen so quickly that we
recognized that the promoter recognized
that we had to book a
another event immediately
uh after you know so the next night we
we so we had two back-to-back events in
vancouver
um
and then yeah those those subsequent
events with you were really a lot of fun
because
we were disagreeing
very stridently about
fairly existential topics
and
by the time we got to london and and
dublin
we had these immense audiences that were
were
segmented in ways that i had never quite
experienced i i've been in front of
you know my home team audience and i've
been in front of a hostile audience but
i've never been in front of an audience
where
you know fully fifty percent or sixty
forty i mean i don't know what the split
was at that point but you know thousands
of people were on one team and thousands
of people were on another team
for questions of god and faith and
meaning and
yeah but everybody was on board for the
discussion you remember one thing that
happened this was in vancouver
we were going to switch to a q a and we
asked the audience essentially if they
wanted the discussion to continue
because we were in the middle of it or
if they wanted to switch to the q a and
it was overwhelming supporting the
audience for the discussion to continue
which i thought was quite remarkable
yeah yeah
yeah so it was it was a lot of fun and
uh it was a tremendous amount of energy
i mean to have
eight or nine thousand people show up
for a uh an intellectual discussion
really i mean
it did have the character somewhat of a
debate but it was not framed as anything
like a formal debate and we were really
just having a conversation and
agreeing where we agreed and disagreeing
where we disagreed and it was um
anyway i i found it to be a lot of fun
and it was ridiculously exciting yeah
and people people loved it so yeah i've
yes and so what do you make of that it's
like why in the world was what it was
that we were talking about
attractive to so many thousands of
people
well
you know when you look at the full sweep
of what we cover i mean in those
particular conversations we weren't
focusing on areas that we we agree about
much more i mean we you know you and i
if you're going to turn us loose on
questions of um
you know moral panic around identity
politics and social justice hysteria you
know you and i will agree i think
probably 90 percent or more on many of
those topics
uh
and i don't recall us touching any of
that but that but that was in the in the
background
it was certainly it was certainly the
the wind in your sails you know making
you more and more prominent at that
point because you had hit those topics
so hard
um
but
you know the topics we were touching
questions of
of
you know what is reality and how we
should live within it really you know
the fundamental questions of
of you know what it means to live a good
life what are the requisites for living
a good life
how should we think about our place in
the universe so as to have the best
chance of living a good life
these are the most important questions
anyone ever asks provided they have
sufficient freedom to even worry about
such things right i mean just if the
wolf is at the door or in the room
well then people really for the most
part don't have the luxury of
of worrying about whether they're as
ethical or as honest or as
profoundly engaged with the
the present moment
um
as they might be
but once you get
to something like you know first world
concerns where you have enough
material abundance where you know
survival is not a question and when
political stability is sufficient that
you're not continually worried that
you know your neighbors are going to
murder you um
then you're then it really
i mean then then we
you know when you when you wake up at
three in the morning and can't get back
to sleep you're thinking about
what what does this all mean and what's
you know what is a good life one of the
things that we did agree on i think that
sort of provided a container for the
discussions
in total was that
there was potentially such a thing as
the good life that that's just not some
you know epithelial abstraction or
something like that
but something central and
to some degree i think we disagreed
about
where the information for deriving what
might constitute the good life comes
from but it isn't even clear to me
exactly where those differences lie and
that was part of i suppose the fun of
the discussion and something that i also
hope to continue today because i've seen
since then it seems to me that you've
turned your attention more and more
perhaps not more and more but you
certainly continued your route into
investigation of what constitutes the
good life and
and also your attempts to bring what
you've learned to
under perhaps an increasingly wide
audience using the technology that
you're using now i have this app that
you have which is the waking up app my
wife has um subscribed to that for the
last year and a half and i joked with
you earlier that she probably spent more
time with you than she has with me in
the last year and a half so that's quite
quite comical but she finds it's quite
useful
and and i took a good look at it today
how does
tell me about that app and why you're
doing that are you doing that instead of
writing a book or is it another book and
why are you doing that well i seem to be
doing everything instead of writing a
book
the writing a book has has become an
opportunity cost that i can't
justify at the moment but no doubt i
will write another book at some point
but yeah between my podcast and app
that's really those are the two channels
where i am putting out my ideas at this
point
so why did you switch to that because
well i looked at the app and one of the
things you're doing is you've broken
down lectures in some sense
into like 10-minute chunks that are
focused on different topics a whole
variety of topics i've got the app right
here and
um
assuming my phone
so
there's groups of lectures fundamentals
mind and emotion the illusory self
mysteries and paradoxes and some of the
topics for example the illusory self
uh
self and other alone with others looking
in the mirror the art of doing nothing
mysteries and paradoxes what is real
consciousness the mystery of being
in some ways it looks like a book right
it's got chapters it's got sub chapters
but why why this why this technology and
and how is it performed for you in
comparison to a book
well so i did write the book version of
this content or certainly most of this
content so i i have a book waking up
and
it touches you know it is my attempt to
ground
so-called spiritual experience
experiences like self-transcendence and
unconditional love and
the kinds of things people experience on
you know various psychedelics you know
this is all of increasing interest to
people now i wanted to ground all of
that in what i consider to be a rational
empirical understanding of the world
right i didn't want to believe anything
on insufficient evidence so as to
prop up
the
[Music]
the importance of these experiences
because they don't they don't actually
need to be
propped up by by
by
you know in my view faith or or any
unjustified claim to knowledge
um
and they do you know in at very
interesting points deliver their own
kind of knowledge about the nature of
the mind i mean there are things you can
recognize directly
in your experience
that puts your understanding of your own
subjectivity
in closer register with what we
understand about the brain right now not
everything is is it can be
can be cashed out experientially but
many things can
and uh can i can i ask you one question
well i
okay so that's
there's a bunch of that that i agree
with deeply and one of the things i've
tried to do to the degree that it was
possible when talking about let's say
matters that could be religious i've
tried to stay out of the religious
territory as much as possible because it
seems to me counterproductive to make an
appeal to faith would you can make an
appeal to well what would you to it not
just to experience it's deeper than that
to something like the combination of
experience in science so let me run
something by you as an example and see
what you think of this because one of
the things that we really
sparred about i suppose or discussed was
the the is art conundrum right right we
agree that you have to have oughts
because you have to act and that's that
landscape of value but we ran into some
trouble i think trying to
make our viewpoints about where those
oughts might be derived from you seem to
be more
convinced than me perhaps that the step
from is to ought was simpler and i was
more convinced that it was more
complicated and there were problems that
still remained there
i'll let you respond to that but i
wanted to talk about this deeper
experience so i was standing with my
wife the other day on the dock of this
cottage we have up north and it's very
dark up here and so when you look up you
can see the night sky well enough to see
the milky way and actually to see
galaxies if you use the corner of your
eye and
and so
and one of the things that's associated
with that is an experience of awe and
it's not surprising because there you
are confronting what's essentially
infinite as far as you're concerned as
as much as it might be for us
and
i thought a lot about the experience of
aw
one of the things and it's also produced
by music quite regularly one of the
things that happens when you experience
awe is that a vestigial pilo erection
mechanism kicks in and that's the
mechanism that makes prey animals
puff up you see this with cats they're
quite funny when they do this
they puff up so they look bigger
in in in this when they catch sight of a
threatening predator and so they perhaps
subjectively experiencing experience
the more terror stricken end of awe but
that awe is very very deep it's not a
it's not a rational
response it's way underneath rationality
it's an instinctual response and
it seems to me as well that it's
associated very tightly with our
instinct to imitate
and it's strange to think that you could
look at the night sky and that could
catalyze
a
in an instinct to imitate but we're very
we're very good at using abstraction us
creatures and it's not exactly obvious
what we can imitate and what we can't
so i think that's an example of this
idea that you're putting forward that
the domain of religious experience let's
say a spiritual
experience has a
uh
biological underpinning a deep
biological underpinning and you know
part of my question is what's the
what are the implications of that
exactly if that if that happens to be
the case
so first i'd like to know if you agree
about that discussion about awe and
there is an odd thing and then anything
else you'd like to add i'd like to hear
yeah we've opened many doors there
that's a i see a 10-hour conversation
but treating just those topics but
um
well to start with the azot bit
you're in very good company most people
in science and philosophy as you know
believe there really is a a
disjunction between is and ought and
to follow hume's
really cast aside remarks i mean he
didn't go into it deeply but but at one
point uh
he wrote that you can't derive
an art from an is right there's no
description of the way the world is they
can tell you how it ought to be so
um
and he was he was decrying the fact that
so many scholars and then in general so
many theologians in his time would move
smoothly from is to ought without
acknowledging that they had had
committed a logical error
but i do think there's a trick of
language lurking at the bottom of this
is an odd talk that is
misleading and
um
and it's it's difficult to spot and you
know i believe i've spotted it and and
but i i do you know the people who don't
agree with me don't agree with me i mean
that their intuitions don't pass through
you know the point where i'm i'm trying
to shove them
um
and you know it's somewhat analogous to
um
you know the philosopher wittgenstein
made a point when he was criticizing
freud he was criticizing freud's notion
of the unconscious he didn't he thought
this reification of the unconscious was
was fallacious and you know we can leave
that aside i don't you know that's
uh i'm not sure i agree with him there
but the the point he was making about
the power of language was interesting he
said
imagine
if instead of saying
uh i saw nobody in the room
we said
i saw mr nobody in the room imagine a
language that forced us to say i saw a
mr nobody right
just just
imagine what confusion would be born of
that convention of language that's
something he said in his i think was in
the blue book
and there are many places in our
thinking about the world where language
plays a similarly confusing role where
we have reified something
which is not probably happens with free
will yeah no so i think it's a confu
it's confused us about free will it
confuses about about
death for instance i mean i think
well you know if you're an atheist who
doesn't believe that anything happens
after you die right if you think
uh there's there's no rebirth you know
there's no reincarnation and and that
eastern picture of karma and rebirth is
probably not true and you think there's
no heaven or hell and if you really
think you get something like a dial tone
when you die
well
many people are left expecting some kind
of oblivion some kind of positive
nothingness some some some permanent
loss of experience where and so this
notion of nut of
of oblivion
um
is a kind of reification
uh but if you if you think about it more
clearly that's precisely the kind of
thing you would not except i mean if if
it's simply the end of experience well
then
you're not going to be experiencing the
end of experience right this is not you
didn't you didn't experience an absence
before you were born right well the idea
that you would experience is implicit in
the way the question is framed right
right right so there's no there's
nothing you're going to suffer this is
something that epicurus
pointed out
through
lucretius that you know death is nothing
for us you know we're where we are death
is not and where death is we are not
right like there's just non-overlapping
sets of facts whatever those facts are
if in fact death is the end of
experience so which is to say there's
nothing to worry about really if if uh
if death is is just the end of anything
um
and so how do you think that relates to
what is odd yeah so to come back to to
is an odd i just think
really what we have i mean forget about
morality forget about questions of good
and evil forget about uh
any value judgment
what i
and try to return your mind to something
like the primal circumstance of
consciousness right i mean just just
imagine waking up from
you know a 100 year sleep
and you've forgotten everything about
yourself and now you're just a mind in a
world
in some sense we're all in we're all
potentially in that position
in every moment in our lives you know
just seeing
creation afresh right seeing this moment
of seeing hearing smelling tasting
touching
thinking for you know as though for the
first time you know clearly do you know
that have you ever
heard
of the neurological case i think it was
a man who had bilateral hippocampal
damage he was in the psychiatric
hospital and he woke up like that every
second yeah
yeah his wife would come in the room and
he'd say it's as if it's as if i'm
seeing you for the first time he lost
that right he lost the imposition of
memory on his perception and so every
perception was fresh and new yeah well
so and i'm not recommending brain damage
to anyone as a way of freshening up
experience but there's a there's a
non-neurologically compromised way of of
grasping this intuition which is it just
in this moment
you know
experience really is
potentially totally fresh and totally
new
and
it but for the fact there's this there's
this ever-present layer of our thinking
about it our remember remembering what
just happened are expecting the next
thing that's going to happen that's
really the conversation we're having
with ourselves in each moment and
meditation is a way
of breaking that spell and actually
being vividly aware of the present
moment in a way that that frees you from
this automaticity of just
viewing everything through your through
your concepts and your discursiveness
that's a neurologically justifiable
viewpoint too because it looks like
the hippocampal map that more or less
keeps track of in some sense our
memories and then also of our
conditional positioning in the world
is likely
either
it's inhibiting that more primal
perception although it's doing it in a
very useful manner generally speaking
because it keeps us oriented enough in
the moment so that we focus on minut the
minute details that might be necessary
to our survival but
it's it's conceivable that it's
simultaneously blinding to blinding us
to a broader and deeper reality that in
some sense is deeply nourishing in the
face of suffering yeah yeah and and
what's more the the mechanism
that is tiling over reality with
concepts in every moment and keeping us
thinking and persevering about our
experience rather than
recognizing that we're identical to our
experience
um
let's table this part of the discussion
for a second this would go under the
question of what is the self you know
what do we mean by self and what might
tran self transcendence be but
this whole mechanism is productive of
most if not all of our psychological
suffering right like there's just
yeah you know all of our anxiety and
depression and fear and regret and shame
and and
an inability to love even the people we
ostensibly love you know
in our lives
you know the contraction into self that
is so
toxic so much of the time
um
you know all of our deferring our
happiness to some future time where
we've met all of these goals that that
that raise our status in comparison with
you know everyone else we're comparing
ourselves to that whole stratum of
of being a person
is a confection of endlessly thinking
about ourselves about our past and our
future and even our present
and it's possible to punch through that
whether it's through
you know using psychedelics or
practicing meditation or just having
just a a collision with the present
moment that's engineered by something
you know you're someone close to you
dies or say you know something
something changing music can do that
yeah you can do that and dance can do
that or you know in certain cases the
you know the aw you describe looking at
looking up at the the milky way right
that can do that for people
um
okay so let me let me but i just i just
didn't answer your i didn't answer your
question
the
this
this notion that there's
there's this separation between facts
and values right doesn't it doesn't run
through when you when you think of what
this primal circumstance is like where
you have to figure out
how you when you have to make sense of
the world you have to you have to
try to understand what is going on in
the world
and
you have to most importantly have to
figure out what to do next right so i
view so
you you can forget about morality forget
about science forget about anything
for the moment
and just recognize that
the world is such
that we are confronted with a an
ever-present navigation problem we have
this the possibility of navigating both
personally and collectively
to places in the space of all possible
experience
that are just manifestly terrible you
know and and the worst place i call the
worst possible misery for everyone right
so it is possible to imagine a universe
where every conscious system
suffers as much as it possibly can for
as long as it can you know some some
version of the perfect hell right
and then there's then it's possible to
recognize
that whatever you want to call it
whether you whether you want to use
words like good and evil or right and
wrong or not
every other place on the what i call the
moral landscape is better than the worst
possible misery forever right i agree
with that completely that that's why i
studied atrocity for so long because i
figured if i could find out what the
worst thing was
that would be a pointer to the best
thing because if you know the worst
thing then the opposite of that is the
best thing whatever that is that doesn't
mean you have to propositionalize it
it's not even that easy to do and there
may be many opposites of that it may not
just be one
best possible place on the landscape
there could be many peaks and valleys on
the moral landscape and there could be
peaks that are not equivalent in
anything but the fact that they are
equally distant from the worst possible
misery for everyone right so there could
be
so i'm not you know this this can sound
like moral relativism but it's not it's
it's it's an objective picture of
morality i think it does
but it's just to say that there are
there may be there may be very different
ways of living
where given the given the
the right kind of minds involved
you could be happy in very strange ways
and in ways that you know would be
counterintuitive for you know apes like
ourselves
um but nonetheless they could be very
far from the the worst possible misery
for everyone
so in any case i call this so so
whatever you want to call navigating in
this space moving away from just
uh unendurable pointless misery right
toward
you know beauty and creativity and joy
and love and you know all of the good
stuff we recognize and again there's
there's there's no we haven't seen the
horizon of this we have no idea how
beautiful life could be for
for minds like our own or minds you know
significantly more sensitive and
creative and intelligent than our own
i mean there's there's nothing i had a
vision of heaven as a place that was
perfect where everyone that was in it
was striving to make it better
right right yeah so there's there's some
we don't know how good things can get
and we don't know how bad things can get
but we know they can get quite terrible
from where our current vantage point and
we know they can get quite wonderful
from our current vantage point and
this is where the distance between facts
and values collapses for me there are
writers let me ask you let me just land
this final sentence there there are
right and wrong answers
with respect to how to navigate in this
space right there there there is it is
and they're right and wrong whether
we've discovered them or not right we
could all be wrong about the thing we
should do next so as to be
as happy as possible you know we could
be
we could think we're
doing something very wise and
compassionate and useful and actually
we're
you know slowly poisoning ourselves with
some you know toxin that we haven't
identified right i mean so they're thing
so it is truly possible to not know what
you don't know
it's truly possible to not know what
you're missing right for there to be
some happier place on the landscape that
you could get to if only you knew to try
to get to it
but you're not trying to get to it
because you're satisfied
you know drinking 12 beers a night and
you know cheating on your wife or
whatever it is
you could have a whole civilization that
is unaware of just a local peak yeah
exactly a great one it's a local peak
but yes
uh not as good as it might be um so
there's there are
there so there are two ways to see that
this in my view that this this
disconnection between facts and values
collapses first
you need to you need to value certain
things in order to get any facts in hand
in the first place any statement about
facts
relies on having first valued
things like evidence and logical
coherence right if you're if you don't
value logic
there's no logical argument you can give
someone to say that they should value it
if someone doesn't value evidence
there's no evidence you could give them
to say that they should value it so that
so it you know the epistemology sort of
bites its own tail
or put or picks itself up from its boots
right now that actually that actually
harkens back to the is ought problem
right because
right there you said
and i'm not denying the validity of
anything you've said so far but right
there you said that
without agreeing on the validity of
evidence let's say
there's no agreement about what is
and there we've got a frame problem
there right
we have that value that you need to even
determine what is well the question then
is where does that value come from and
you can't say well it comes from what is
in some easy manner because you just
said unless you have a value of a
certain sort you can't derive what is
and that's partly why this odd is is
ought problem just doesn't seem to go
away
yeah but so but it goes away because it
goes away the moment you recognize
there is in principle always a mystery
at our backs
you know this is true experientially i
mean i say i would say this is true
experientially with respect to the
nature of consciousness but it's true
conceptually with with respect to even
those fields
that pretend
to be most directly in contact with the
nature of reality i mean so even physics
you know when you're talking about the
most rudimentary laws of physics right
there is still
there has to be a first brute fact or a
or a brute axiom
that you accept
that doesn't that need not prove itself
right there's no self-justifying
epistemology
yes well that exactly yes i believe that
well i think that that's why there is an
emphasis on faith in some principle in
so many religious traditions
is that there is a starting place there
and you're you're trying to flesh out
where that is at least to some degree so
let let me ask you
a couple of that mention one thing and
then ask you a couple more things so
this is what distinction is even more
peculiar when you look deep into the
neuroscience of perception okay so one
of the most influential books i ever
read was an ecological approach to
visual perception
and it's a classic text on perception
and a very sophisticated one and i don't
think it
what it has no pretensions to mysticism
of any sort
and so that's kind of interesting given
the conclusion and the conclusion of the
author
is that
what we see
aren't facts or objects
we see meanings so for example a
six-month-old who
crawls towards a visual cliff which is a
plate of glass stretched over a or
placed over a falling off places
the the six month old will stop he won't
crawl
seven months i don't remember the exact
she won't crawl across that piece of
glass right he doesn't see cliff and
infer falling off place he sees falling
off place and there's a condition called
neglect which is characteristic of
certain people who have pre-frontal lobe
damage called sorry it's not neglect
it's called utilization behavior yeah
and these people lose the ability not to
act in the presence of a meaningful
object so if they walk down the hall and
the door is open
they will go through the door
if you put a cup in front of them they
cannot stop but pick it up because they
don't see cup and infer drinking they
see a drinking object directly and so
even
that is ought distinction is is
deceptive in a very fundamental sense
because it's predicated on the idea that
what we see are meaningless objects and
that we lay an overlay of meaning on top
of that and it's not by no means obvious
at all that that's how we see yeah and
that's part of the reason why it's been
so difficult to make machines that can
see and act in the real world because
the object world is not simple and that
value structure that you're describing
that over that
that value structure right
that is embedded in all of our
perceptions in ways that we are only
beginning to understand scientifically
yeah
there's so many ways in which our
oh you know what's called folk
psychological
sense of of what our minds do
uh is is just completely broken right
and we have we have a sense of
of
the tools we're using to do anything you
know that beliefs desires
perceptions
uh expectations
uh the movement of attention right and
our sense of what all of this is
uh from the first person side
has definitely broken apart in in many
respects as we've studied these things
neuroscientifically from psychologically
from the third person side and
understanding ourselves understanding
the world and our place within it and
what's possible
is inevitably a marriage of those two
sides i mean you can't you can't fully
banish
first person experience because they're
me
most of what we we know about ourselves
has a cash value in terms of the
experiential side i mean you know to
take the
the greatest case
there's simply no evidence of
consciousness
anywhere in the universe but for the
fact that we know it to exist in
ourselves from the first person side you
can't look at a brain
even a living one
and have and form any intuition that it
it's a locus of consciousness it's only
by correlating changes in the experience
of living people
with you know tools of neural imaging in
this case or things like eeg
where we say okay well when the brain's
doing that there's something that it's
like to experience those changes right
and that and and we pretend rather often
to take
the third person science side off the
gold standard of first person experience
and say okay that's really you know the
mind may be an illusion you know maybe
even consciousness is an illusion what
we know is happening is that our brains
that are processing information and
we've got things like synapses and and
neuromodulators and neurotransmitters
and that's the real stuff right that's
the reality this mind part is
is some kind of um
right that's a definition it's not an
observation it's just a tissue of
confusion reality right that's a big
problem yeah there's no you can't you
can't banish the the the
the side which is in fact
uh cashing out so many of your claims
about
the nature of in this case the brain
and
but that's not to say
that
we can't be deeply mistaken from the
first person side about what our minds
are doing i mean so you know i might you
know as you as we've indicated here
already
i'm an enormous fan of meditation i
think it's i think it's indispensable
for understanding certain things about
the nature of the mind
but
you you can't even tell that you have a
brain by meditating right much less you
you know what it's doing right so it's
like it's that there are things that you
there there are some major blind spots
in first-person experience no matter how
you train
experience
but you can notice for instance that
the sense of self the sense that you're
a subject interior to your experience
the the you're a kind of a locus of a
consciousness
that is
appropriate in experience
that is that is an illusion or at best a
convention right a kind of construction
that you can cease to construct and
so much of um so why why do you why do
you believe that that's so useful
right there's something core here yeah
no it's a great question i want to make
i want to make one observation before we
go back to sure so
well
one of the things i learned when i was
studying ancient egyptian mythology
was that the egyptians
worshiped
horus that's the eye
yeah and we may have talked about this
before but
they weren't worshiping rationality they
weren't worshiping that monkey mind
they were worshiping attention itself
and they regarded attention as the
process that revitalized dead
totalitarianism because they had a god
for that that was osiris
and so
there's something
and
when the egyptians were
contemplating what constituted proper
political sovereignty
they regarded the union of osiris and
and horus as the emblem of proper
sovereignty and that was the osiris that
was rescued from his totalitarian state
by his union with horus
so it's like the conceptual world which
tends to ossify
like
well like egypt in the exodus book
and the attention process which
focuses perhaps on what's outside of the
of totalitarian certainty and therefore
continues to update it
and that's not rationality and i think
it's pointing to something that's
similar to what you're fascinated by
with your concentration on it i think
it's on attention
per se
it's not rationality it's certainly not
correct it's not the contents of thought
it's something more like direct
apprehension and you know in clinical in
clinical practice rogers carl rogers
particularly
taking a bit of a leaf from freud but
he said that if you attend
to your clients which meant listen to
them but it meant attend it didn't mean
engage them in rational dialogue it
meant more like listen
they will transform psychologically as a
matter of course
right
yeah so i use attention as slightly
different way or a more
specific way
and differentiate it from something like
consciousness or awareness itself so
that like so
and this is i think this is i mean i'm
sure there are different ways of using
it but um
one tends to meet this definition now in
in cognitive science and neuroscience
where
it's a narrowing of the field
of awareness but there's still a field
or there's or it's like a spotlight
within within a larger field so for
instance i you know i'm looking at you
on zoom now
and i can look at it i can look at you
know one of your eyes right i can
specifically
look at that eye and i can focus on that
but there are many other things that i
within my visual field that that i'm not
focusing on but which are never the less
there
and one of them could suddenly capture
my quote attention right so i'm looking
at your eye i'm doing my best to look at
your eye to the exclusion of everything
else but if you know if a mouse ran
across my desk all of a sudden
that would have a hundred percent of my
attention and that so it's that shift
it's the shift of the spotlight
that that's the that's the attentional
mechanism that is happening within this
larger context of what i would call
consciousness or awareness because it's
you know so you're using attention as as
the scientist like yeah like the fovea
right exactly so it's the kind of the
cognitive phobia
where so that's where consciousness is
most intense right because those neurons
are each neuron in the fovea is
connected to 10 000 neurons in the
primary visual cortex
so it's it's tremendously dense
cortically and then so you could think
of maybe we could distinguish these two
concepts this way so at in the center of
your vision at the fovea it's
extraordinarily high resolution
consciousness which we call attention
and then as you move out from the fovea
to the periphery your your consciousness
becomes lower and lower resolution until
out here if you're speaking visually you
can't even really count the number of
fingers that you see you can see the
hands only if they move and out here
it's black and white and out here it's
gone yeah high resolution foveal focus
and you can move your eyes to put that
high resolution
high neurological vision
to work
yeah i would i would use the terminology
a little differently here though because
i wouldn't say that consciousness is
diminishing
at the edges i would say that the visual
perception is so consciousness is just
the fact
that anything is being known right so
you can be conscious for instance of
a very blurry vision right or you can be
conscious that you're blind that you
can't see anything right but like if you
just close your eyes now
even your visual consciousness
is just as present it's just you're
you're just aware of the the darkness
behind your eyelids right and it's not
even all that dark there's it's
scintillating with various colors and
right so okay so we could say that
you've got that high resolution
attention in the middle then it gets
lower resolution right to here where you
can't see and then that's
all
contained within
a broader attentional field
right yes and i would call that that the
broadest possible field just
consciousness okay more awareness fine
so okay so now we know exactly what we
mean by our terms and so and so what i
would
what i would say is to your question
which i think is a very important
question what's the point of
examining the self you know much less
transcending it
um
there are several points i mean what the
main one is that it is the
the
string upon which all of our suffering
is
is strong i mean it's just it is just
it is when you feel as miserable as you
can feel
that sense of being at the center of
this
uh
torment
uh and like which of what what direction
will you find relief right i mean this
is this is just this is you've got
the cacophony of the unpleasant
experience and then you've got this
place in the middle of it or a parent
place in the middle of it from which
you're trying to resist this experience
right or figure trying to figure out how
to change it right so let's say you have
a
terrible pain
you know somewhere in your body
you know there's the pain there's a
strong
stimulus of unpleasant sensation you
know the burning and and stabbing and
twisting feeling
and then there's this reaction to it
from apparently some point outside the
pain
very likely you know for most people up
in the head i mean most people feel like
they're a subject
in their heads
that is
not not
truly coincident with the rest of their
body they don't feel most people for the
most part don't feel identical to their
bodies they feel like they have bodies
and these bodies can misbehave in
various ways and again so you have a
terrible pain
the pain's down there let's say it's in
your knee
you're up here
now a a a hostage
being tortured
by the misbehavior
of the rest of your body right and
you're resisting you're trying to you're
trying to find some way of resisting
these sensations
um
and so it is with emotional distress or
unpleasant thoughts right you know that
you can have thoughts that terrorize you
um and all of it seems to suggest i mean
this is you know this is the extreme
case of
stark uh unhappiness but even in the
best of times right even when things are
going really well and everything
experience is very smooth and
we're getting what we want and you know
we
you know our favorite treats are just
an arm's length away and we're
filling our mouths with with gumdrops or
whatever it is we're
we're gratifying this thing at the
center of our experience and it can
never be finally gratified because
experience itself is impermanent it's
just you know it's just you you get to
the thing you want
and you gorge yourself on it and then
you don't want a new thing you want a
new thing you know you then you need a
drink of water because the the this this
lingering taste in your mouth of
chocolate mousse or whatever it is is
too clean and too much and you got to
wash that out so that you just you
wouldn't want to stay in that state even
if you could
and there's some there's there's kind of
this rolling dissatisfaction
even in satisfaction
that we all encounter even in the best
of times right even when you literally
can get anything more or less anything
you want
and and yet we know
at any moment it can be subverted by
something terrible happening you know at
any moment you can suddenly feel like
you're
you might be having a heart attack right
and then that becomes
the thing that the
this sense of me in the middle of
everything collapses upon
and
um
and it's it is it makes life i mean this
this again the sense of of of being
in this vulnerable center right it makes
life this kind of long emergency
that can be pacified by
you know increasingly strenuous efforts
to control experience right we have to
control this thing because
at any moment it's just we're constantly
just if you just look at any moment we
might die yeah yeah we're avoiding death
you know but even you know even for
those of us who don't think about death
very often and there are those people
we're constantly
modifying our experience so as to to
avoid discomfort whether it's social
discomfort or physical discomfort or
just every
every correction in our body if you if
you just try to sit still for an hour
you'll notice that
all of the micro adjustments of in
posture that you're now no longer making
are made because you really don't have
to wait long before you feel miserable i
mean your body the amount of pain you
can get just sitting in the most
comfortable chair you can find in your
home
and just resolving not to move is is
quite extraordinary it's just you know
it's it's just
there's no position that's comfortable
enough that it will be comfortable an
hour from now okay so when you when you
rise out of that into this meditative
state like what what's your experience
and what has that done for you
personally and ethically
um
okay so so the starting point which i've
just
dimly sketched out of being a subject in
the head right i mean this is something
that
i i will be familiar to 99 of our
audience or you know 99.999 percent of
our audience
people feel that they are they don't
feel identical to their bodies they feel
like they have bodies and now you know
they might be told okay you might want
to look into this practice of meditation
you might want to just understand
yourself a little better
here start with this practice you can
close your eyes and pay attention to the
feeling of breathing you know the
sensation of breathing in the in the at
the rising falling of their chest or the
air passing in their nostrils
and every time you get lost in thought
just come back to the raw sensation of
breathing that's a very you know basic
exercise of you know what's called
mindfulness
and the moment you try to try to do that
you begin to discover or you know some
moments down the line you discover that
it's very hard to do that your that your
default state
is to get distracted by a conversation
you're having with yourself
and to forget all about this project of
paying attention to the present moment
and it could be it doesn't matter what
it is but you know the breath in this
case
and
and so it is in fact true to say that
for most people i mean literally 99.9
percent of our audience
uh
they couldn't pay attention to the
breath
for a full minute say
even if their lives depended on it right
it's just like it's simply not in the
cards it's not it's you know the fate of
the world could depend on it and
someone who's not really fairly well
trained in this
uh just couldn't do it and so that's
interesting right what's interesting is
that despite your best efforts
you get carried away by thought
helplessly moment after moment
now
being able to break that spell being
able to see thought as thought
eventually once you get some degree of
mindfulness
in hand
you no longer confine
your attention to the breath or any
other arbitrary object you begin to open
it up to everything you can possibly
experience so it's just you know sights
and sounds and sensations and emotions
and
and thoughts themselves
can become objects of
mindfulness
but when you can but this is where this
is the kind of cru the crucial you know
kind of almost binary
difference which
which produces an immense amount of
psychological
benefit
the moment you can really notice
thoughts themselves as appearances in
consciousness rather than
what you are in each moment because what
happens is in the default case
the thoughts kind of creep up from
behind us in some sense they kind of
come out of nowhere
and that just feels like me right so i'm
you know i'm trying to
it's a reflexive identification yeah you
wouldn't act the damn things out if they
didn't feel like you you know and so
they have to have that impulse to action
in them that that's part of felt
identity right so you're saying that
you're saying and this is part of i
suppose part of the buddhist tradition
particularly although not only that
being the the puppet of those thoughts
is part of what prolongs
suffering at least under some circuits
especially being the puppet of them yes
okay yeah and so and so this is so but
the the people you know listening to us
now
can feel this so you know that you know
we're talking and people are trying to
understand the threat of this
conversation but it's comp they have a
voice in their head that's competing
with this right they you know they're
trying to listen to us but they're also
thinking right and they think so they
might think
what the hell's he talking about right
like there's just some some intrusive
thought comes in or like oh no wait a
minute he didn't answer the question
that
thought that that feels if you're
identified with it if you don't see it
as mere language appearing in
consciousness or mere imagery right
it feels like me it's like that is the
self that isn't it feels like what i
believe yeah that's just that that's no
space
yeah well one of the things you do in
clinical work all the time especially in
the cognitive behavioral field
is you help people
identify those thoughts in some sense as
as objects
to no longer identify with them and to
say you know just because you think that
it's not necessarily true it's not
necessarily you and it's not necessarily
helpful right now we can check and see
if any of those three you know
propositions were true maybe it is you
maybe you do believe that maybe it is
useful but we're going to start by
hypothesizing that some of these
automatic thoughts are actually what's
driving your misery
and i really also see that as a
tremendous danger of totalitarian
ideologies because their thought systems
that are almost entirely foreign in some
sense to the individual person
that invade that cognitive space that
you're describing and then manifest
themselves as unquestioning identity and
if they're blinding the person to some
underlying reality that's actually
revivifying and nourishing and an
antidote to suffering then they're a
tremendous block to exactly that process
yeah yeah so so there are two levels at
which we can address this problem of
thought and it's its connection to
suffering
uh and one is at the level of thought
itself right so you can you can replace
bad thoughts with better thoughts right
you can you can you can get some you can
triangulate on your your tendency to
have one kind of conversation with
yourself
uh and engineer a better conversation
with yourself right and that's you know
then yes and cognitive behavioral
thinking like a six year old for example
and start thinking like a 30 year old
right right and right but what's more a
30 year old that actually has good
intentions for you right like that you
could a friend yes right you can make
your mind your friend yeah yeah loved
one even yes yeah yeah can you imagine
that
so uh imagine that so that's that's a
that's a totally legitimate way to to
climb out of of the the great whole of
of suffering
that people find themselves in
um
but there's a there's a more fundamental
and and i'm not i'm not saying what you
know
what i'm what i'm recommending in terms
of you know meditation mindfulness here
is more fundamental but it is not it's
completely compatible with that you know
more conceptual discursive layer right
and some things i would argue some
things are best addressed on the
discursive layer and some things are
better better addressed on the on the
the more fundamental layers well you
know when you're sitting meditating
first of all you're sitting
and so it's perfectly reasonable to
adopt a mode of thought that's healthful
and productive in relationship to the
fact that you're sitting you know those
more discursive propositional thoughts
that we've been describing they're
they're higher resolution in some sense
and they're more practically
implementable and so there's going you
want to get that in order but that
doesn't mean that there
that this phenomenon that you're
describing that's outside the entire
discursive structure doesn't exist right
it's probably also the place we go at
least to some degree when we go to sleep
and we dream and get revivified it's
outside that discursive landscape and
that's necessary for physiological
rejuvenation
yeah well dreams are very interesting
because i i think they are necessary and
we know a lot about the necessity of
of rem sleep for health and so there's
no question that dreams are doing good
things for us
but they also are
an experience of
stark psychosis you know i mean they are
they are a condition unless you're
unless we're talking about lucid
dreaming this is a circumstance where
you really have no idea what's going on
i mean you you are in reality asleep in
your bed
and yet you have transitioned into
another experience
which where the laws of nature are
violated you're talking to dead people
you're you know
the sky is the limit right and you're
not even surprised you're doing so
little reality testing you're not even
surprised about these changes you have
so little purchase on who you were just
15 minutes ago when you went to sleep
that it's so that means
it does mean it does mean to some degree
at that point though that you have
suspended your unthinking identification
with your daytime propositional thought
yeah yeah but you but in in the normal
case you're identified with your dream
body and and your dream persona and
whoever you whoever you've become i mean
you're you're being terrorized in a in a
in a more malleable
right with the identity
is still there yeah it's just it's it's
it's
it's more random and less logically
coherent and there's something there
about
exploration and change of categories
themselves that's going on but i can see
your point about it still being well
part of and more to the point if there's
actually a very close connection between
what happens with ordinary thought and
dreaming so for instance
uh
i mean or ordinary thinking is
it to in my view or ordinary
identification with thought i'm not i
don't mean to demonize thought per se
because we need thoughts and and the
goal of meditation is not to get rid of
thoughts is to be able to recognize them
as as what they are and to recognize the
process of thinking
um and to break this this this pseudo
identification with it but the
identification with thought is very much
analogous to dreaming and not knowing
that you're dreaming and the switch from
a normal dream to a lucid dream is
analogous to to the kind of waking up in
the middle of life that i'm
i'm advocating here where you can
actually just recognize thoughts as
thoughts and there's something that the
way in which
thoughts steal over us where so you're
trying to pay attention to something
and then all of a sudden you're you're
replaying an argument that you had with
your wife you know yesterday right
and helplessly and and it's actually
it's it's it's dredging up the emotion
that is appropriate to that argument
right so now you're getting angry or
regretful or whatever it is um
it's it's quite crazy it's totally
normal i mean this is the default state
of most people most of the time
but
given how unhappy
the character of our conversation is
with ourselves most of the time given
that the stories we're telling ourselves
are less than
perfectly inspiring and perfectly
ennobling and and uh you know
great you know opening us to great
reservoirs of compassion and wisdom
right they're not doing that um
it's worth looking into this and it is
it does have this dreamlike character of
both
coming out of nowhere and seizing
completely seizing the reins of of
attention and identity and taking us
elsewhere
and
also we forget it we it has a that's
part of the totalitarian spirit of
rationality that proclivity
well but it is but a lot of these
thoughts aren't rational it's just it's
just you're just rehearsing your
experience it's just like you'll tell
yourself the same thing 10 times in a
row and never and you won't be bored on
the 10th time you'll you'll like if you
just imagine
what it would be like to externalize
your thoughts on a loudspeaker for
everyone to listen to
you know and you were just you just it
was just helplessly you know
externalized
every every normal person would sound
insane you know because because of the
the perseveration and the
and just the redundancy and the
and the strange structure to
the discursiveness i mean this is this
is a um
you know this is ever present it's so
it's so ever present that it strike it
doesn't strike people as strange but to
be presuming we have a we have a
dialogue with ourselves as though the
eye could talk to the me
and that made any sense at all it's like
you know i'm sitting here
and you're getting set up for this
interview right and
i i'll think um
oh i got to get some water right
now
i know
if i'm the one to say it
and i'm the one who here is
i know i need water who am i telling you
it's like it's like i'm telling someone
else right who needs to be informed
about this well you're probably telling
the prefrontal cortex and it tells the
motor cortex so you know it's that's
probably the hypothalamus talking to the
prefrontal cortex because it doesn't
have direct output over the motor cortex
it's something like that
yeah it remains to be seen whether any
of that is actually functionally
necessary but i i think for the most
part
it's not i mean for the most part we we
simply talk to it's almost like we
started talking to our parents
you know once we once we had once the
language is incredibly useful as you
know and it's it is what defines us as
as people in many respects
and once it gets to it's it's like once
it gets tuned up
it never shuts off and
you know we're talking to it so you know
first we're pre-linguistic and we're
just drinking in language that's aimed
at us you know
all the time our parents are jabbering
to us
we begin to understand what they're
saying as so much of it is you know
indexical they're pointing to things and
we're naming those things we're hearing
the word the sounds associated with
those the things that are being grasped
and handed to us and um
and soon we begin to participate in this
language game in ways that we're not
conscious of and once this gets tuned up
we talk to our parents we jabber to our
parents incessantly and then we jabber
to ourselves when they leave the room
and it never stops well you know in in
mcgillcrist and i have talked about this
issue
and
he he's
of the opinion i hope i'm not
misrepresenting him and and it's an idea
that i had shared to some degree is that
the the right hemisphere
in many ways this is in left-handed
people at least
in some sense is more regulated by the
underlying limbic structures the
motivational structures like an animal
is
and and the left hemisphere to the
degree that it's linguistic it inhibits
those right hemisphere functions
tonically and that's likely speech
and what that means implies perhaps is
that if you can shut that speech off
there's a different mode of perception
that's characterized by the right
hemisphere's immersement in these
underlying motivational systems
that might be part and parcel of that
revivification possibility that you're i
think you're pointing to
as something that lies outside the
linguistic landscape
and that can become maybe hyper dominant
has become hyper dominant in us
because we're so immersed in language i
mean from what i can tell i mean thus
far the the research on the the
neuroimaging research on meditation is
you know still
in its infancy despite the fact that
there have been hundreds and even
thousands of paper papers at this point
on meditation
but
you know
silencing the default mode network is
certainly part of the
the footprint of of the change here that
is relevant and the default mode network
for people i mean many people have heard
of this by now but it used to be kind of
an esoteric
topic but just a brief review
the default mode network is
called the default mode because it was
noticed in virtually every neuroimaging
experiment ever designed that there was
this the system of structures in the
midline of the brain
that would would increase their their
activity
in between tasks so whatever the
paradigm was if you're giving people a
reading task or a sensory task or a
memory task or a
visual discrimination whatever it is
you're putting them in the scanner they
have to pay attention to something
in those epochs between tasks when they
were no longer having to pay attention
to something that they're waiting for
the next thing to be presented to them
this these set of structures in the
midline would increase their activity so
it was called the default mode
uh it's just the kind of the brain's
idling state but these are also the
structures
that that seem to have a
disproportionate amount of
responsibility for
self-reference and self-representation
and and they get tuned up even further
when you give people tasks that require
a set a a a retrospective analysis of
the self you know if i if i gave you a
list of words and i was saying
i asked you to decide you know which of
these words apply to you and which of
these words don't apply to you as a
person right that's the kind of task
that would increase you know be above
baseline activity in in the default mode
network
um
and there are other components to this
uh
you know even sort of questions of
identity i mean a lot of that is is
in whole or in part mediated by the
default mode
um and it this is what becomes
noticeably quiescent when you are
successfully practicing mindfulness and
it becomes quiescent
in in those experiences with
psychedelics where the sense of self is
is
transcended for a time now where
linguistic communication often becomes
extremely difficult yeah yeah but people
experience but so what's interesting
here is that
that you know i i think people
you know ordinary people who do not take
psychedelics and have no interest in
meditation
do
experience interruptions in this sense
of self a lot that just go unrecognized
and sometimes they go recognized
because their
their so-called peak experiences or you
know flow experiences where you know
they'll you know even the kinds of
experiences you referenced you know
looking up at the milky way you know the
the most
beautiful encounter with with um
a starry night you have you know in that
decade say you've gone to the place
where there's the least light pollution
and you've got you know a cloudless
moonless night and then you you point
your gaze
skyward and you get the full experience
that's you know
there there are two experiences people
tend to have when they when they have
sought out a peak experience like that
if they're lucky
they really have something like a moment
where they're lifted out of themselves
and they they can just
have something like this breathtaking
encounter with nature right
and then all too often
that lasts you know a second and a half
and then they're just talking about it
and thinking about it and trying to get
back to it but they're they're still
just jabbering to themselves and to
you know whoever's with them very likely
trying to get a hold of this thing where
if you took mushrooms or if you took
acid in that circumstance well then your
linguistic
you know efforts to to get this thing in
hand are completely blown over
and you have the full you know
multi-hour encounter with the thing
itself right and it's
you know that's what that's what's so
amazing about psychedelics is that
whoever you are i mean this let's leave
aside the prospect of having a bad trip
which we you know
about which many interesting things can
be said
the the so-called good trip you can have
on mushrooms or lsd
is this condition of
the data of your senses and you're in in
particular
in in a circumstance like the one you
described your engagement with the
natural world becomes so
vivid so salient
that
the boundary between self and world is
completely overcome right so like and
the energetics of all of that suddenly
becomes very salient so it's not just
like
you're no longer representing yourself
also the consequences you know you know
griffith's work and if someone has a
mystical experience on psilocybin and
they're smokers they stop 75 percent of
the time yeah it's like they live so far
out of themselves that even their
addictions lift yeah yeah right that's
quite something you know you talk about
being possessed by that default network
well to be possessed by an addiction
like a nicotine addiction is something
like that going wild
and nonetheless
going there apparently
has this transformative capacity you
also see the same thing with treatment
for alcoholics you know i mean for for
years alcohol researchers have known
that the only reliable treatment for
alcoholism is spiritual transformation
and that's hard knows empirical
researchers have been wrestling with
that for a long time
well it can give it gives you the sense
that
you know
again i'm not i'm not claiming that the
the
the beatific vision that one has on lsd
or psilocybin is necessarily the the
true target state of one's spiritual
life i mean it's you know in some ways i
i think it's not
it's there's something misleading about
it but at a minimum these this this can
end to the continuum of positive
experience
you know just just being flooded with
bliss and and completely overcome with
with
an encounter with the present moment and
and meaning you know just the perception
of meaning whether that meaning can be
rationally justified in the end right
because literally you can
if you're in the right state of mind it
doesn't matter what you're looking at it
doesn't have to be the milky way you can
just be staring at a you know a puddle
in the concrete in a parking lot and all
of a sudden that is the you know the
answer to the mystery of existence right
so in some ways it's it's
it's potentially you there's a place to
stand where you can pathologize this you
know ex this herophony of of meaning
but you know leaving that aside leaving
that criticism aside the experience
itself proves beyond any possibility of
doubt
that it's possible to have an utterly
transforming transformative
and
uh totally satisfying encounter with the
present moment that isn't itself
dependent
on anything happening it's a quality of
your attention now neurochemically that
something obviously has to happen in
order to
to allow you to pay attention that fully
to anything
but there is a way of granting your
attention to the present moment so that
the sacredness of anything
comes fully into view so okay let me i
got a couple of questions for you on
that so let's go back to this starry
night idea so i want to tell you a story
i was i was talking to my wife today
about the fact that i was going to talk
to you because she's been following your
meditation course but at the same time
that she's done she she
she was
she had a medical death sentence two
years ago yeah fundamentally
okay so she's been through a variety of
forms of hell and has come out the other
side and has changed
in consequence of that and
one of the things she started doing as
well as doing your meditation course was
using the rosary so i asked her today
she's also been talking to the jonathan
pago who's an extraordinarily
interesting
religious thinker who carves icons he's
a former french canadian young guys very
very deep person in my estimation
in any case she's been praying the
rosary and i said okay so well you do
that and you listen to sam's meditations
and so how does that work and she says
well i do the rosary first
i said well what do you why do you do
that and what do you do and how do you
see them related and she said well with
the rosary so she's she's concentrating
on mary and she said mary's uh
as a conduit to christ and i'll explain
what she meant by that in a sec but
um
she she it's a i said she she said well
first it's a practice okay so she does
it every day so it's an embodied
practice right so she says the words and
she moves these beats and so she's
moving her hands and there's
it's divided into five sections and so
when her attention wanders from prayer
it's brought back because there's five
sections right so you imagine you have
this tendency to wander off into the
default network and but by manipulating
something with your hands it ties you to
the present moment yeah okay so it's a
meditative practice uh that that's more
embodied than just sitting still say and
she finds that useful and
and while she says the words well we've
talked a lot about what these words mean
and so
in reference to the starry night for
example there's this series of
renaissance paintings which are quite
magnificent that show an image of mary
with her with 12 stars around her head
and with her foot on a serpent
and that's that's an allusion to the
garden of eden because
uh well eve crushes the serpent beneath
her foot and so and this is relevant to
your discussion and our discussion
earlier about the deepest of all evils
right because that that's a concern of
yours it's being a concern of mine
what's the darkest possible place well
the
that snake in those paintings represents
that and that's why in christianity the
snake which is a predator is associated
with satan right as the as what would
you say the emissary of evil or
malevolent something like that
and so
because mary has her head in the stars
she can have her foot on the
serpent
and that's part of that meditation and
while she does that before she listens
to your meditation
but
that's where i see the
the psychological link let's say because
you want to put your
psyche in the highest possible place
whatever that is and we don't know what
it is exactly but it's something like
what happens when you look up at the
night sky
it's something like that and if you do
that that means that your foot is
simultaneously on that serpent
yeah no i mean i don't have any um
first of all it's wonderful that
she's using the app and getting some
benefit from it i i love that and
there's no and my and the juxtaposition
of doing the rosary
with doing you know what i'm
recommending the app is not as
odd as you might
think it is in my in my view i mean i
have you know it's
there's so much
of um
there's so much there's so much
resonance between what i think is true
and the kinds of things jesus said right
my only
my my issue my issue with organized
religion every organized religion
is just that clearly
what we're really talking about
are deeper universal truths about the
nature of of mind right maybe you know
whether would you
limit it to human minds or just mind
itself consciousness itself
and so there's no culture there's no
religion there's no
provincial
uh
cult
that has
the full story and what we really really
the burden on us in in in every present
generation you know but certainly now in
in
the 21st century where they're all the
barriers to to
to um
uh
universalization yeah all the barriers
to infra you know getting information
and translating from other languages all
of that's broken down we have we have
access to everyone's ideas right there
have been a hundred billion people and a
bunch of them have had good ideas a
bunch of them have had bad ideas and we
have access to
to
thousands of years uh yeah human
conversations yeah my only argument what
those ideas were my only argument is
that
we should only care about using the best
ideas
uh and we should and we we no longer
have
the right to
any deep
serious sectarianism right now we can be
that's not to say that you can't be
especially taken with
with jesus and the tradition that has
grown up around him
uh and
you know you're not so you're kind of
bored with socrates and so you don't
spend as much time with him and that's
all fine but the the problem i i've had
traditionally with organized religion is
religion
historically is the only
corner of culture
where people begin saying to themselves
and to their children
we're playing a totally different game
over here this is not just this is not a
matter of just ideas and human beings
and human conversations and ordinary
books no no these books
were written by god or inspired by god
you know and
uh they can't be edited and
uh everything i think it seems to me
that laying
the danger in that i i'm not disagreeing
with you
but
it seems to me the danger in that is
that it it actually minimizes the
problem of atrocity that's associated
with sectarianism because
and
you can heap as many atrocities as you
want on that side of the balance i i
will agree with you well okay so this is
what i'm pointing to though because
we're having a dis discussion in some
ways about sacred things and so and then
we're talking about the issue of
religion and so there's a couple of
things i want to say about that
dostoevsky had it right to some degree
in the grand inquisitor
because the do you remember that story
the grand visitor yeah i mean i i'm sure
it's been been many okay now several
decades since i actually read the book
but well the remarkable thing about that
story is christ comes back to earth
and he does some miracles and it's the
church himself that puts him in jail and
then the head of the church comes to the
jail and says
what the hell are you doing back here
the last thing we need is you we've got
everything sorted out we know what's
going on it's like we're going to put
you to death tomorrow
and then christ kisses him on the lips
and the grand inquisitor turns white
and then when he leaves the grand
inquisitor he leaves the door open
and that was that's so brilliant and you
know dostoevsky was writing at the same
time as nietzsche and
had quite an influence on nietzsche as
it turned out
and but because dostoevsky was writing
fiction he could go places
that dostoevsky couldn't go as a
philosopher
and one of the things he was trying to
point out was that
despite the proclivity to
totalitarianism that you can lay at the
feet of sectarian religion
the door is left open
and you know all of us have to come to
terms with the fact that our
institutions religious and otherwise
tend to ossify into these totalitarian
structures that are analogous socially i
think in some ways to the default
network that you just described
they're trying to point to something
beyond that but you know they degenerate
and ossify and then but but then we have
to go underneath that too if we're going
to get our criticisms right because as
terrified as it's reasonable to be about
religious sectarianism and
totalitarianism it's also necessary to
remember that chimpanzees go on raiding
parties
yeah and and kill the neighboring tribe
so to speak and they're not motivated by
religious concerns and so
to to put that at the feet of religion
even implicitly i think is
i understand
why
that's an impulse
but it doesn't
face the problem deeply enough and it
also obscures a potential solution i
think because it tends
it tends to throw the baby out with the
bath water and i know you're trying to
regain the baby yeah no i'm trying to
save the baby yeah yeah no i i love that
baby
um
yeah i mean for me the
the crucial variables that make um
religion
itself so problematic are one
the religions and and this is true of
the the abrahamic ones in particular
the religions that are focused on a text
right that can't be edited now you you
religious moderates and religious
liberals will
disagree with me and they'll say that
the whole tradition is a matter of
you know reinterpreting and grappling
with the the the contradictions and the
um and there's a that's of all a very
rich discourse and blah blah blah but
the the real problem is
the books themselves
betray their merely human origin
on almost every page you know there's
just like you know
it's true of the plays of shakespeare
it's true of the iliad and the odyssey
it's true of of uh virgil it's true of
dostoevsky and it's true of the bible
right in all its parts right so there's
just there's and
the you know if you just imagine
how good a book would be could be if it
were
truly written or dictated
by it by an omniscient being
i mean it's it's just
it's trivially easy to imagine that yeah
but jesus would be so much better than
they in fact are it's really not that
easy to translate the sorts of
experiences that you're pointing to into
words no no no no i know i matter right
no but it but you can you can do
concepts and words well but even well
okay okay let's talk about that for a
minute better and worse because that's
really that that and and i want to tie
this back to your comments about
navigation earlier
so you know we do have and this is
perhaps an issue of definition getting
the definition straight again here
we do
have the sense that some texts are
deeper than others and
i don't think it's reasonable to
disagree about that you can read a
shallow story you think well you know
that was shallow and you can read a deep
story and you think that was deep but
you don't know exactly what you mean by
shallow
or deep so
let me just add one one foot note here
which is
somewhat confounding it goes to what we
were just saying about psychedelics it's
possible
for you to be bringing the depth
to a text or to a circumstance or to a
puddle in the in a parking lot
that isn't necessarily there right so
like that like this is where it gets
close to the most modern quandary yeah
like
literally i you know you if you're if
you're going to connect all the dots
you know you can this is something i did
in the end of faith as a as a parlor
trick just because i wanted to prove
this point is that i literally walked
into a bookstore and went to the
cookbook aisle the bookstore and
randomly chose a cookbook and opened it
i opened it up at random and just
just
dictated just wrote down the recipe
and then created a mystical text on the
basis of that recipe and i just i just
showed that this recipe which it was for
some hawaiian cookbook was like wok
seared fish and shrimp cakes or
something
and i i took the ingredients in that
recipe and wove a completely
confabulatory mystical
text
out of those ingredients now that that
was something i was bringing to the text
there was no author
uh uh creating that document that's
clearly a problem and look i actually
and the truth is
people can always do that right so that
that's it's very hard to keep score here
and to be
and to be
rigorous all we can do is
again and again have this this
experience of
you say something
that that
on your own side purports to be
meaningful and intends to be meaningful
and you're trying to convey something
and then i and other people
seem to grasp what you're communicating
and we have this intersubjective
convergence which is increasingly
satisfying and yes so i mean but i do
take your point that they're
dostoevsky was writing you know the
brothers karamazov is a deeply
interesting meaningful document uh and
okay so let's take that away let's take
that argument apart
because
you you put your finger on the
postmodern quandary right because the
postmodernists in some sense the reason
that they ran into trouble
with
assuming
they criticized the notion that there
was a canonical interpretation of a text
because there's so many subjective
interpretations of any text
in fact there's a near infinite number
of potential subjective interpretations
of any text just like there's almost an
infinite number of places you could be
looking right now
and so it's a huge deep problem
so so and when you say that you can
project something onto the text that in
some sense isn't there that's also
an extremely deep problem and these
problems are deep enough you know the
fact of multiple interpretations of a
single reality is so
pervasive that it stopped ai researchers
it's the thing that stopped ai
researchers from being able to build
functional robots like it's a killer
problem yeah okay so that's the frame
problem okay so let's let's let's agree
that that exists but we should also
agree and partly i think by the merits
of your own argument that we do have a
reliable subjective intuition
that texts differ in depth yeah and that
that means something so i'm going to
propose what it means and you tell me
what you think about this okay
sure so
one of the ways that we specify
where to look at
is by
looking at what we deem to be important
and so here's a way of conceptualizing
that and it sort of maps onto the idea
of the fovea extending outward to less
high resolution consciousness
so
i write a sentence because i want to
write a paragraph i write a paragraph
because i want to sequence paragraphs
into a book a chapter i write chapters
to sequence them into a book i write a
book because i want to be a practicing
scientist i want to be a practicing
scientist because i'm a good citizen i
want to be a good citizen hypothetically
because i want to be a good person you
know and maybe i want to be a good
person to avoid the hell that you
described
okay so those are nested value
structures
and
we see the world through that structure
simultaneously the whole thing is there
and if one part of it collapses we make
reference to
the part that contains it
that's how we don't crash like a
computer
now that now the navigation that you
described these nested
structures their navigation maps as far
as i can tell
now okay so here's the depth issue
some maps
have more other maps dependent on them
than other maps do
okay so if i go into your
map structure some of that's even
propositionalized and i mess about with
the deeper axiomatic propositions upon
which many other propositions rest
then that's going to disturb you
fundamentally
and that's part of that experience of
depth
and and you know look look you get much
more if you're married and you love your
wife you're much more upset if she
divorces you than if you have an
argument about who should do the dishes
well why well because the stability of
your marriage is a precondition for all
sorts of other ways that you perceive
the world and if that's violated well
that's traumatic
yeah so so when we so and the reason i'm
trying to get this clear with you is
because you think clearly about these
things but also because
it allows
to it allows for clarification of
language in some sense so we could say
that
as you go deeper into that nested
structure
what you approach becomes more and more
sacred
by definition i'm trying to define it
experientially
because the
uh so let's say you're transformed at a
fundamental level
that means something shifts way down
deep
and that's how you feel it even in an
embodied sense
and and what we've defined as as human
beings as religious as far as i can tell
or is sacred is
our attempt to define the landscape that
is characterized by those deepest
structures of maps
now what you're talking about i think is
outside the map system altogether in
some sense
you know it's the container for all of
it
yeah
yeah it is in some sense because
or it's it's orthogonal to it i mean it
penetrates it at every point but it's
not
reducible to it and
i mean that's why it's so consequential
so for instance i think
you can
so taking accepting your your picture of
nested maps and and depth and all that i
agree with all of that
um
and maps can be more or less
useful and more or less in register with
with the the reality they're purporting
to describe right
um so you can have faulty maps
and in science we really try to get an
accurate map and and we we have a high
resolution map yeah and we have a
language game
which is
when it's working
is optimized to you know as richard
feynman famously said not fooling
ourselves right i mean that's like the
master value of not fooling yourself
whereas i would argue in in religious
discourse
not fooling yourself is not a master
value and in fact you know so much of
what goes by the name of religious faith
okay but let me let me put this on
terminology then because you talk about
the sacred
right and and and you accept that and
and you also
and you also see it as revivifying and
and and crucial to the prevention of
suffering yeah but you juxtapose that
against religion and so what what's the
difference as far as you're concerned
between what's sacred and what's
religious
uh yeah good question well so
maybe the best way to get at it is by
reference to a principle which is
i think what i think anything that's
true
right and this is this is true
scientifically descriptively but it's
true spiritually and it's true with
respect to anything we would call sacred
anything that's true anything that's
real
is
discoverable now
right it's like literally like if we if
we lost everything if we lost all the
books if we lost all the tools if we
lost everything and we just found
ourselves
having to reboot
not only civilization but
human cognition
you know
everything that is real
is discoverable
from that starting point if you're even
if you're starting at zero again now we
would we would talk about it differently
we would have you know we would we would
have memories of what you know some of
us would have memories of all that we've
lost and that would anchor us to certain
expectations but
the point is what is true what is real
what is what is what is the real
opportunity for
a direct
self-transcendent engagement with
reality right what what is the real
opportunity for us let me take a
suffering let me take exception to that
in one manner i see what you mean i
understand what you mean i believe
but here's here's a potential problem
with that
so i first i'm i'm not saying let me
just close the door to a possible
misunderstanding i'm not saying
that we shouldn't stand on the shoulders
of giants and i'm not saying tradition
is useless in fact you know i i would i
would probably agree with you
that that we should be fairly
conservative in how we in in how we
overthrow our traditions i mean so i'm
not i'm not arguing that we should just
be radical iconoclasts the tears that we
should tear everything down to the studs
and start again that's not that's not
what i'm advocating well what's the
difference be what's the difference in
your vision then between the tradition
that you would be conservative about
and religion
i'm not trying to corner you i'm just
trying to see how you're making the
distinction conceptually it comes down
to very specific claims that that i
think are
clearly false
and which many of our religions
advertise as not only
important but indispensable for their
projects so take islam as a specific
example
is i mean islam mainstream islam not
just al-qaeda-style islam just any islam
that really is worthy of the name in the
year 2021
is founded on the claim
that the quran is the literal word of
god
it it and it is it is not christian
what does literal mean yeah but
in the minds of most muslims most of the
time it means
that these
stanzas were dictated to muhammad in his
cave by the archangel gabriel
and he was he was commanded to recite
and he recited them and what we have
here
is
in truth the claim the the the the
orthodox claim is
is even more stringent than
what the the seemingly analogous you
know fundamentalist relig you know
christian claim about the bible it's not
just that the text itself
is
is verbatim what god
said
uh
it's the the document itself is in fact
like the the
every instantiation of the physical
document is itself the word of god it's
like it's it's there's sort of a double
layer of sacredness to it
is this it cannot be edited
like this problem that claim or is it
the problem that the people who purport
to understand it claim to be 100
right no no but the problem is is that
given that claim
and given the actual contents of the
book yeah which you have is
an endless
source of
divisiveness and conflict like if you
dignify that claim okay this is the most
important
series of utterances ever expressed on
earth
this is it let's find out what the
creator of the universe wants us to know
what he wants us to know above all else
is that one
we should hate and fear and despise and
resist and never befriend
unbelievers
right that's that's
that message comes through on virtually
every page and a hell has been prepared
for these unbelievers where their skins
will be endlessly burned off of them and
and replenish so that they can be
tortured anew right do you think there's
any relationship between that claim
and your observation
that failure to take refuge in the
sacred as you've laid it out
dooms you to possession by the default
network and puts you into attention
okay so it is
possible to give a very enlightened
reading of this text or really any text
that that allows you to step out of its
divisive and and toxic uh implications
so i would support that kind of reading
you know if if we who were if we were
joined in this conversation by by muslim
scholars who said no no don't you
understand
jordan's
spiritual interpretation
of this
admonishment is precisely what god
intended he intended it to be
to be an engine not of hate
and division and sectarian tribalism he
intended it to be
a device that would allow you to
recognize
the the emotional and cognitive
implications of
of of being caught by dualism say right
like really you know et cetera et cetera
you go as far as you want in that
direction that'd be great the problem is
the book itself gives no indication that
your interpretation is the right one in
fact it gives every indication that it's
not and then
with the sequence of muslim scholars
okay good luck so hopefully well i wish
you i wish you good luck there yeah well
i i i i praying for good luck because
it's an it's a conversation that
absolutely needs to be had yeah clearly
i would agree
sadly but
this chapter i would just say that it's
not that what you're doing with the book
isn't possible
my concern is that
these book these books tend to make that
very difficult and there are there are
other more plausible
uh and easier
interpretations that require less
hermeneutics less cognitive
bandwidth less less principles of
charity and less cosmopolitanism and and
so therefore it's no accident that
you you wind up with something like the
islamic state if you take the quran very
very seriously
and that's that's what worries me as we
as we live in this world where
it's increasingly easy for small numbers
of people to screw up the whole project
for millions of us
you know as as technology you know
leverages the consequence of well that's
why i've been focusing on development of
the individual you know because it is
increasingly possible for individuals to
do that so we have to stop doing it yes
yeah so i'm with you there look i would
love to keep talking to you i i want to
ask you one more i'm getting tired and
that's why yeah no i don't know because
i think
first maybe we should do another event
sure
okay i will talk to my agents
second this
idea you had about escaping from the
text let's say and returning to
existential first principles or
phenomenological first principles
the only objection i can see to that is
that
if you lose
you can't derive the way of producing a
social organization
directly from the existential experience
and so that's a right because you think
look
partly we're going to derive our sacred
values from this lev this strata of
experience that you described but
there's also an element there's also the
fact that we derive our values from
collective agreement
right so we and maybe we feed the
collective agreement with the sacred
experience
but then if we lose that
that collective tradition it's very
difficult to rebuild that from first
principles yeah 100 and and i would say
just to clear up any confusion on this
point i'm not suggesting that
meditation or even the the deepest
insights you can have through meditation
uh or psychedelics
is sufficient
for everything to forget for us to get
everything we want out of life right
it's like it's i i think i i it's proper
use is as you describe is seeding every
other ordinary moment in life with
this capacity to
refresh the mind and
and uh
um
an allowance
revivify the stale dogma of men
just just it is the thing that equips us
to actually be loving and unconflicted
and relaxed in the present moment
whatever's whatever's going on but when
you ask the question
what should we do to build a viable
global civilization there's so many
other modes of
of conversation and knowledge gathering
and
reliance upon institutions and tr and
tradition
that is necessary you know i'm not i'm
not imagining some beautiful state of
nature where we have
lost
our all of the structure that we've
built up over thousands of years and we
just we just meditate as yogi's and yeah
and then try to figure out then try to
call someone when our you know internet
goes down right
we there's a tremendous amount of
knowledge that we need to do anything
well at this point you know as we've
just witnessed in
you know
getting through you know now we're now
into our second year of a global
pandemic right i mean we have a lot to
figure out how do we
how do we even make sense with one
another in the presence of social media
and uh how do we respond when when trust
in institutions has broken down there's
a lot to to figure out and meditation
and
you know psilocybin and any you know and
and
a full speed collision with the with the
beauty and profundity of the present
moment
isn't the answer to many of those
questions it's just it is just it's the
answer to
any other things it's a wellspring you
know like existential dread and you know
uh etc so yeah i mean that's um anyway i
i love talking to you and uh i'm very
happy to see your face and it's really
good to see it again and i remember why
we kept talking now yeah and maybe i
remember why other people came and
listened
and so i would love to do it again sure
sure well because we're gonna we'll
hammer it out you know yeah
yeah
hey good to see you thanks for agreeing
to talk to me again and good luck with
your app and everything that you're
doing yeah and with your orientation
towards the highest good all of that
yeah back at you back at you okay man
take care talk soon okay i'll get in
touch i look forward to it
[Music]
you